l'évolution un sujet passionnant et
justement en parlant de ça nous sommes
tous passés par la case de l'enfance
nous étions une jeune naïf avec un
esprit en constante et à l'époque ma
seule préoccupation c'était mes amis ont
goûté et être un super héros et je vais
certainement vous rappeler quelque chose
mais nous avons tous été des enfants
avec des rêves et des souvenirs
moi pour ma part l'un des meilleurs
souvenirs c'était lorsque j'allais au
parc pour passer mon après midi à ma
musique dans un bac à fleurs en dessous
d'un homme absolument majestueux
d'ailleurs là c'est moi en pleine
construction
comme vous pouvez le bois ma seule
volonté c'était de réaliser ce que
j'avais dans mon imagination et croyez
moi à l'époque elle était déjà
débordement un château de sable
remarques et je voyais déjà les choses
en grand un pont levis un donjon
impressionnant ils doivent profonde et
une princesse
mais alors pourquoi je vais autant ce
bac à sable
la réponse est simple
c'était un espace à investir sans frein
rien ni personne pour brider mon
imagination l'argent ni câble ni
matériel je baignais dans un
environnement positif en tourelle de
simples outils une pelle un seau râteau
incite les compétences pour m'en servir
mais plus amusant c'était de voir les
personnes présentes autour du bac à
sable qui était là en train de regarder
centre forcément comprendre que j'étais
en train de faire et cette sensation on
l'a déjà tout vécu ou comme moi quand on
travaille sur un projet qui nous tient à
coeur et que personne ne nous comprend
souvent je me suis demandé comment c'est
tarbes avait grandi au milieu de ce bac
à sable
mais la vraie question est est ailleurs
qu'est ce qu'il y avait en hausse de 7,1
et les années ont passé
j'ai grandi j'ai bien peu de poids et
une fois l'adolescence j'ai voulu
répondre à cette question alors un matin
sans trop forcément savoir qui est lui
même était passé par la paix j'ai décidé
de grimper pour aller récupérer l'une de
ses plus hautes feuilles et en faire un
trophée personnel c'était mon objectif
j'ai alors commencé à m'agripper
aliments ce feuillet présent dans son
coeur et là j'y suis allé franco la
droite gauche pied droit pied gauche
je ne regardais pas de soldes parce que
je savais pertinemment
faire peur et j'arrive au tronc je tombe
sur des branches plus solide un peu
fatigué je m'arrête en soufre en
profitant cette subtile position et
finalement la dernière il reprend le
dessus et je reprends mon ascension du
coup vous connaissez la musique main
droite main gauche qui est droit si vous
suivez
je continue je monte je monte et
j'arrive jusqu'à la cime de l'arbre et
d'un incroyable ça faisait partie de ses
sensations qui démarre en bas de votre
dos remonte le long de l'eau verte m
jusqu'à arriver à votre esprit
incroyable g j'ai pris une claque
j'ai profité de la vue qu'offrait cette
position j'ai saisi cette feuille que je
convoitais depuis des années et à cet
instant j'ai constaté que de toutes les
difficultés qu'il y avait autour de moi
alors que je prenais suffisamment de
hauteur
ces façons disparaît pour laisser place
à un horizon brillant on se confronter
d'un côté les problèmes et de l'autre
les solutions mais toutes les bonnes
choses ont une fin et rapidement
j'ai été ramenée à la réalité par mes
parents inquiet par ma prise de risques
alors volontairement je ne vous parle
pas de la suite un enfant dans un arbre
yvette de haut les parents un peu
stressé bref ça a été une expérience
formatrice et douloureuse et les années
sont encore passés j'ai grandi j'ai pris
un peu de musique beaucoup d'assurance
et aujourd'hui à 24 ans et bien
j'ai toujours autant d'idées et
d'imagination lui trotte dans la tête
tout le temps et c'est parfois difficile
de faire la part des choses et ce plus
je ne voyais pas à l'époque c'est que
cette situation quand est-ce qu'on est
parfaitement à ma façon de penser et
avec l'aide d'une de mes mentors agnès
bihl son mourier j'ai réussi à la
représenter à la conceptualiser et en
faire une matrice je vais utilise
régulièrement dans mon travail pour être
original cette matrice je voulais amener
la matrice abs et tout comme cette
situation dont je vous ai parlé
son fonctionnement est simple d'abord le
bac à sable c'est votre mode de pensée
ensuite vient la dans les nuages
on a une question les fuck cap que
l'information les ratifications ouvre à
la réflexion le tronc vous donne la
solution et les racines vous donne le
plan d'action qui pratique
non je rigole mais finalement qu'est ce
que vous allez pouvoir donne au passage
que j'étais un simple enfant qu'il
aimait s'amuser dans un bac à sable
un des deux dessins un peu acrobates ou
encore un jeune adulte qui se prenait
pour un culturiste sur un tennis on est
tous d'accord ce n'est pas terrible mais
ce n'est pas ce que je veux alors je
vais vous montrer son application pour
que vous aussi vous c'est comprendre son
fonctionnement
et pourquoi pas l'utiliser l'un des
meilleurs exemples
c'était pour la réalisation de mon
master j'avais moi même formulé ma
problématique
et attention comment innover dans le
secteur du bâtiment
ça l'est déjà songeur et c'est la pch
d'utiliser les feuilles quelques
l'information provenant de nombreux
domaines architecture agriculture
démographie bactéries intelligence
artificielle
les ramifications ouvre à la réflexion
ces moments où j'ai croisé mais
différentes données pour pouvoir attirer
des pistes de recherche
vient ensuite le drone qui concentre les
solutions pour en obtenir trois grandes
idées sur lesquelles j'ai travaillé une
intelligence artificielle pour assister
des architectes des fab labs implantée
chez les distributeurs bataillon ou
encore un robot capable de créer des
structures à partir du sable en plein
milieu du désert et une fois ces trois
courses idées mises en valeur il ne me
reste plus qu'à les développer avec les
racines qui me donne le plan d'action
comme vous pouvez le voir avec cette
matrice
on peut obtenir des idées puissante qui
aujourd'hui sont nécessaires pour
continuer de se développer de voir
exploser sa créativité de toujours
rester dans son imagination d'avoir un
mode de pensée qui serait plus récréatif
car comme le disait l'entrepreneur
américain seth godin dans une place de
marché concurrentielle être normal s'il
échoue dans un marché saturé ne pas se
démarquer signifie être un dc alors
maintenant que vous avez compris la
particularité de cet arbre
il s'adapte à chacun de vous à chacune
de nos façons de penser
il peut être mis à disposition de
n'importe qui l'entreprise de
collectivités entrepreneurs étudiants
car
car aujourd'hui je n'ai fait que vous
présentez l'idée semer la graine
arrosez là avec tout ce que vous verrez
ce soir et fait légèrement nos limites
[Applaudissements]